what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting back into super Suns
really the conclusion of super Suns
which is actually really really good
this brings back something called hyper
tong and in truth we've kind of seen
hybrid time sporadically throughout DC
rebirth and in all honesty I thought it
was a concept that I would never have to
talk about I was hoping it was something
I just kind of avoid and just not really
discussed because Hypertime is not the
best idea I mean it works for the
purpose it serves and it would have
worked better if everybody had used it
the problem is that they didn't sowhat's
Hypertime
okay Hypertime was DC's attempt to copy
marvel's handling of the multiverse so
with Marvel let's say that you have like
a singular line on a piece of paper so
this straight line represents the main
Marvel Universe now this line has been
destroyed and created multiple times in
fact eight times to be exact
because the multiverse has been created
and destroyed you know eight different
times so we have this straight line and
this main line is just the main Marvel
Universe this is the story where Bruce
Banner became the Incredible Hulk this
is the story where the original Civil
War VIN happened so this is the main
Marvel Universe line but let's say
somewhere along this line we put a dot
and we can call it 1984 and we can say
Peter Parker becomes venom alright so
this isn't this is Secret Wars in 1984
and this is the story where Peter Parker
discovers the venomous Indian but let's
say within this dot the following events
happen Secret Wars 2000 Secret Wars 1984
takes place Peter Parker discovers the
Venom symbiote Peter Parker brings it
back to earth and then Peter Parker goes
to visit the Fantastic Four and Reed
Richards says that's actually a sentient
symbiote that you're wearing is a
Cinthia organism it's not just a black
suit and it's trying to take you over
and so Peter Parker cast it off all that
takes place in that little dot now let's
create a branch off line alright so we
have a line that branches off and goes
forward keeps going along the forward in
the same forward direction is that main
line now we can say in that line Peter
Parker does not get rid of the venomous
idiot that is how Marvel handles their
multiverse it's branching diverse theory
you have a main set of events to take
place and then it's but what if
something else happened instead and then
it branches off into an alternate
universe now we never really find out
what happens in the future of those
alternate realities we get a story about
one moment in that alternate reality
another one of those lines maybe what if
the Punishers family was not killed in
the park shootout that's what those
little branch off lines are they're just
moments in time where things broke off
from the main Marvel Universe now this
is how DC handles the multiverse so
we're gonna have three lines we're gonna
have one line under that we're gonna
another line and that we're gonna have
another line and the very top line is
called earth one and the very bottom of
the second line is called earth two and
the very bottom line is called earth
three and that's it that's how DC
usually handles their multiverse earth
one is all the stories that have Barry
Allen at least before Christ on Infinite
Earths all the stories that have very
Allen and before crisis on Infinite
Earths earth 2 is all the stories that
had Jay Garrick basically all the DC
Comics in the 1940s and earth 3 is
called the crime syndicate of America
where the Justice League were bad guys
now let's say all three of those lines
suddenly stopped we could draw a line
right through them write that line that
goes through all three lines that's
crisis on Infinite Earths all those
those all those universes are gone there
is no more earth one earth two or three
earth s none of that stuff exists
anymore instead coming out of those
three lines we have one line and that
line is called new earth that's
everything after crisis on Infinite
Earths running all the way up to 2006 is
Infinite Crisis and that's it it's just
one line one universe everything that
happened in DC Comics between 1985 to
2005 all happened in that one line now
2005 Infinite Crisis brings back those
three lines is basically what it did but
during the time when everything was
operating on that one line Grant
Morrison and Mark Waid had this idea and
they said well we can't do alternate
realities anymore because there are no
more alternate realities so instead what
we're gonna do is we're gonna invent
Hypertime and what we're gonna say is
that instead of there being alternate
universe that have always existed out
there will say alternate timelines
basically it's the same thing it was
bringing back alternate realities were
just calling them something else and so
what they said is well maybe the flash
goes back in time and does this and
instead of things happening the way they
always did on that one line then it
branches off into another line and
something else happens and it was
bringing in all these different
alternate realities now it would have
worked basically what you would have had
is DC's version of Marvel's handling of
alternate realities and that would have
been it the problem is that no one used
Hypertime except for like Grant Morrison
and Mark Wayne and so what you had had
is in the flash stories you would have
you have events that would take place so
there'd be alternate realities and then
you wouldn't have that anywhere else and
so it threw the reader off and he
confused the heck out of him because
people were like but I thought there was
only ever one timeline but you read the
flash comics and it's like well there's
a ton of timelines there's all these
different alternate realities out here
all these crazy things and people are
just like but that doesn't make any
sense
what DC did at least what they seem to
be trying to do with regards to DC
rebirth and especially new 52 is they're
trying to blend
in Hypertime with their handling of the
multiverse
so what DC basically says is yet there's
these alternate realities out there
earth one or two or three like they
presumably exist out there somewhere we
don't really know what's going on with
them and we don't know exactly how it
all fits in because of what I meant what
Manhattan's done but we can say they all
exist out there but in addition to those
universes that have always been there if
the flash goes back in time and changes
something well then Hypertime gets
invoked and it's an alternate reality
and that's what this story is this story
is basically DC's version of Marvel's
what if what if lines the stories that's
what you could imagine this to be if
this story super sons of tomorrow was
thrown into Marvel Comics it would be
what if Superboy killed everybody like I
mean that's basically what it would be
you know what if Superboy killed a
million people in DC Universe that's
what the story would be called is
essentially a future where Superboy had
killed a million people for whatever
reason which we'll talk about in this
video and then basically that futures
version of the Justice League and Tim
Drake who is Batman went back in time to
try to stop it that's basically what
this is so if that has melted your brain
a little bit feel free to kind of scroll
back and watch it a couple more times
hopefully it makes sense and it kind of
seeks them or give yourself a few
minutes I know that when I read things
that are kind of confusing I have to get
myself maybe 10 or 15 minutes to kind of
let it sink in and then it'll understand
then like it'll make sense to me and
that kind of a thing but the fact
remains you know getting caught up so
far we've pretty much run over it I mean
Tim Drake is basically Batman from the
future he showed up and he's trying to
stop some event that will lead to
Jonathan Kent the son of Superman
killing a million people the result is
that where he initially where Tim's I
could initially shown up and then
basically ambush the Titans and then
tried to overpower Jonathan Kent the
result was that Jonathan Kent had
basically charged up and led off this
massive amount of solar energy now the
issue with this is that with Jonathan
can essentially knocked unconscious what
happened is a Tim Drake used it as a
means to argue see I was right I told
you guys he was dangerous now this is
one of those things where Tim Drake
caused the problem that he was trying to
avoid or at least showed people what it
wasn't that Jonathan Kent could do by
pushing and prodding him but he actually
has a point if Tim Drake was able to
push Jonathan Kim to the point where he
would let off this solar you know solar
flare of sorts albeit with a small
amount of damage imagine what would
happen if somebody the Jonathan Kent
truly trusts had pushed him to the
extreme and force him to just let off
this massive amount of energy not only
that what if he flew into the Sun and
absorbed all this solar radiation came
back to earth and then exploded imagine
the damage that he would do then and so
that's the concern that Tim Drake has
Jonathan Kent's gonna destroy metropolis
in the future he's going to kill
millions of
and it's a scenario that can be avoided
it's Tim Drake's attempt to change the
past now picking up with Jonathan Kent
of course having been rescued by Damian
Wayne the interesting thing about this
is that Damian Wayne looks at the solar
flare of Superboy as something that can
be used where on the surface most people
would say well it's exceedingly
dangerous and they could result in the
destruction of everything and Damian
Wayne's mind it's this idea if Jonathan
can be taught how to control it then
it's a power he can use so long as he
doesn't love use it or anything like
that but in in Damian's mind the reason
why you know Tim Drake's future came
into existence was because Jonathan
developed its new power and there was no
one there to teach him how to use it now
again the other half of this is of
course the Teen Titans of tomorrow and
this brings back some characters that
have been missing for quite some time
cassie sandsmark connor can't bar talent
of course we did an explanation video on
Bart Allen which you're welcome to check
out if you want a wholesale
understanding of his character but the
fact remains that they're basically the
Teen Titans of tomorrow they're the Teen
Titans of the future Bart Allen of
course playing the role of the flash
cassie sandsmark playing the role of
Wonder Woman and Conner Kent playing the
role of Superman again we don't really
know what happened to their normal
stand-in characters but the result is
that Tim Drake kind of comes from their
future and it's sort of interesting
because it seems like there's a bit of
not really distrust so much as a
disagreement on what role they should
take where the Teen Titans seem to have
just kind of been like well I mean you
know if we could stop it that's cool Tim
Drake is like well then let's actually
stop it he just jumps into the past and
tries to find a way to take out Superboy
Jonathan Kent now it is kind of
interesting because of course as we saw
in the first video Tim Drake had
incapacitated both Batman and Superman
which removed them from the equation and
at that point it was really just kind of
left to the Teen Titans to try to pull
it off and where Tim Drake initially
meets with the other Titans absent
Damian and Superboy who are currently
you know on the road recuperating Tim
Drake actually makes a pretty compelling
argument Superboy doesn't know who I am
but if I was able to push him to the
extreme to the point that he would lose
his mind and he would basically destroy
the entirety of titans tower then what
does that say if someone like Damian
Wayne betrays him he trusts you guys he
believes in you guys and he cares about
you guys if you betray his trust or you
push him to the edge the amount of
energy because it's directly intertwined
with his emotional state means that he
would be even more heartbroken which
means it would be even more damaged and
so again it's actually pretty intriguing
and it's a pretty legit argument the
other half of this is the nature of
Raven in the sense that Raven almost
sort of goes along with this idea of Tim
Drake and she really kind of
into it you know her argument is look if
what you say is that Jonathan Kent has a
level of power that he hasn't really
experienced before he's got a new energy
this super bomb that he can't really
control and that a time will come when
someone will push him to the edge his
emotions will get the better of him and
he'll wipe everything out of existence
then we have to control him we have to
contain him if for no other reason than
to keep him in stasis so we can teach
him how to use his powers you know it's
really one of those things where it's
like work capturing him but we're doing
it for his own benefit and it's kind of
intriguing because this creates a rift
of sorts among the Teen Titans the
scenario on one side you know Aqualad
and and Starfire's you know let's not be
so heavy-handed you know there's a lot
that we don't know about all this
the other side of Raven is but we have
Tim Drake here and he's already given us
the future so we know what's gonna
happen and that's why it's so cool
that's one of the reasons why the
writing of Teen Titans was so popular
and remained so popular among fans it's
not a pretty white kids with problems
comic book it's a story where it's like
man these are some serious issues that
these kids are dealing with and a lot of
philosophical themes and different
things like that now of course the other
half of this is that in the future
Connor can't cassie sandsmark and Bart
Allen they're trying to locate Tim Drake
within time the problem with this is
that remember when you're in the future
and you're looking at the present day
you're basically looking at a flowing
river and so you know if you have like a
pod or you have like an object sitting
in that River it's not still it doesn't
just stay there it doesn't sit in one
place it flows along the river so what
they're literally trying to do is cast a
fishing line and try to grab that object
out of the river it's gonna be hard to
do
you can't just reach and grab it because
once is there now in an instant it could
be somewhere else and it could be
anywhere along the time stream it's a
needle in a haystack
so the cool thing about this is that
Raven you know while the the future
Titans are trying to anchor on to Tim
Drake and while they do manage to get
ahold of it which basically says look we
can now track his location
Raven basically uses a little little bit
of telepathic voodoo offers a
distraction of sorts you know has
everybody fixed Titan Tower and then
just disappears alongside Tim Drake and
Beast Boy and it's kind of cool because
in their mind you know in the minds of
all these different superheroes
everything's being fixed and the -
Starfire and Kid Flash and in Aqualad oh
man they're fixing Titans Tower we'll
take care of that first and then we'll
go after Connor camp but in reality none
of that's happening it's just as in
shambles as it ever was
and siliceous again the telepathic
powers you know the telepathic abilities
that Raven has to kind of mess with the
minds of people which is kind of cool
but at this point we switch over to the
really the last bit of the story
switching over to you know the
and number 38 and again this really
picks up with the idea that the Teen
Titans to a degree feel kind of a trade
by Raven but using the powers of Aqualad
are also able to locate where it is that
Jonathan and in gaming and Wayne are
located now of course once they find
them then it's like okay we have to
figure out a way to contain this
situation now of course the immediate
reaction of both Damian and Jonathan is
one to attack and it's also kind of cool
because where Damian Wayne did assemble
his own Teen Titans and where each
member of the Titans do have their own
history either as heroes or just kind of
living in isolation but are well aware
of their powers and what they're capable
of Damian Wayne's job as leader is to
know their strengths and weaknesses and
so while he has no powers to speak of he
does have the mind of Bruce Wayne which
means he knows how to easily overcome
each and every one of these Titans now
of course this leads to a stalemate of
sorts just because of the fact that
aqualad's like look guys enough like
this is ridiculous we need to calm down
everybody needs to chill and we need to
talk this out what this also leads to is
the arrival of Conner Kent and Bart
Allen and cassie sandsmark now it's not
immediate instead it's actually Superboy
saying okay look if everybody's really
on the hunt for snow jonathan kim's like
if everybody's really looking for us
then we have to go to the fortress of
solitude it's the safest place for us to
go it's virtually impenetrable except by
those who know explicitly how it works
which is to say those who could speak
Kryptonian or understand the Kryptonian
language which were forced Tim Drake
does which is how he was able to
penetrate it because he was taught by
Conner Kent in the future but it is cool
because when they get there the place is
in shambles because remember at the
beginning of the story Tim Drake showed
up he used his knowledge of the
Kryptonian language to infiltrate the
fortress of solitude and then subdue
Superman
now the other half of this is Jonathan
now this is kind of cool because what
Tomasi is doing is it almost kind of
seems like he's drawing on a bit of
dragon ball if I'm gonna be honest with
you guys it's almost kind of what it
reminded me of I mean I don't know if
Peter Jay Tomas he watched his dragon
ball or even knows what it is but it is
kind one of those cool seeds you know
back when dragon when Dragon Ball Z
first launched Gohan was first
introduced when his father was in a
dangerous situation
go Hans power would emerge through his
emotional state and he would let off
this massive amount of energy his power
level would skyrocket
you know and it would get really really
cool is one of those funny things his
power was tied to his emotions the
angrier he got the more reckless and the
more powerful he got until he was able
to control his fighting abilities and
different things like that but with
Jonathan Kent is the same way because
it's his dad it's his anchor to the
world he lives in rescuing his dad from
this container also sets in motion the
idea that Jonathan Kent has
supernovae power that he can't
necessarily control and in this instance
because his emotional state shifts in
the extreme his power is just kind of
started running a ride to the point that
he can't control him and this energy
starts building up and this proves the
argument of Tim Drake someone is going
to push Jonathan Kim to the edge and his
emotions are gonna take over reason and
logic will take a backseat his power
will start surging and start enveloping
outwards and when it does a massive
amount of energy is gonna explode and
that's gonna be the end of everyone and
so it's cool because with the arrival of
Bart Allen with the arrival of cassie
sandsmark with the arrival of conner
kent we basically get them fighting
alongside Superman and the modern-day
Teen Titans at its roof this is a Teen
Titans dream I mean those people who
were reading BC back in like the 1990s
were just like yes those folks who are
reading reading a young justice in the
early 2000s they're in the exact same
boat it's it's a return to familiarity
for them even if it's only momentary for
those existing fans they finally get to
see Conner Kent alongside Superman they
finally get to see Bart Allen return to
the DC landscape cassie sandsmark yo the
second Wonder Girl they get to see all
these things begin to sort of grow and
progress and so on and so forth and
things begin to kind of shape up and
take their rightful place now again it's
temporary for those of you guys who are
non comic readers fans see this as DC
kind of opening the door and say hey
guys like look what's behind a door over
here and we're gonna close it back but
like that's what's waiting on you in the
future of DC rebirth and it makes people
so excited because in this moment you
know what this conflict beginning to
sort of wind down what is it taking
place here is that you end up having Tim
Drake who kind of jumps in and absorbs
all this energy that's essentially being
led off by Jonathan kind of absorbs it
into himself and then vanishes into the
timestream now of course this leads
directly into the aftermath but one of
the things that I want you guys to
notice here is that we're Tim Drake
absorbs all those energy and he's just
kind of shot into quote-unquote
Hypertime or into the multiverse we end
up seeing all these different Universal
events have ever taken place this is
very reminiscent of the button remember
during the button storyline when Batman
and the flash were thrown into the
multiverse it was all these alternate
realities as seen from DC universe
rebirth number one the one shot that
said all this in motion when the I guess
when classic Wally West
finally came back you know the idea of
crisis on Infinite Earths is shown here
the original anti-monitor kneel zero our
crisis and Todd when Hal Jordan was
paralyzed and went crazy you know and
killed all the Guardians all these
extremely important moments are shown
here all these things basically every
that's ever happened in DC Comics is
represented in this multiverse and what
this means is that this version of Tim
Drake can land anywhere Tim Drake could
land in the middle of crisis on Infinite
Earths Tim Drake could land in the
middle of Emerald Twilight in the middle
of zero hour crisis and Todd he could
land in the middle of infinite crisis
this is DC reminding us where things
stand there's a reason why you don't see
the original Superman from 1938 here you
don't see Action Comics number one
represented here what DC seems to be
saying is okay so here's how things
progressed Barry Allen went back in time
and saved his mom's life and that spawn
flashpoint and Barry Allen's like man
this flashpoint universe sucks so I
gotta let my mom die in order to make
sure everything goes back to normal he
goes back in time to let his mom die and
things were supposed to go back to
normal but like dr. Mann hadn't
intervened for some reason and we don't
know why and changed everything and so
we got all the stories from 2011 going
forward until DC universe rebirth number
one that seems to be what DC sang here
I'm not gonna take that as an absolute
certainty and we won't really know until
the whole rebirth initiative ends and
then we're with the final DC universe in
terms of my hey we're done changing
everything we're done ret counting
everything we are finally done we're off
to the races now here's how it's going
to be going forward we won't know until
we get to that point until presumably
Doomsday Clock ins is really what I
think all that so I think Doomsday Clock
will be where we learn everything that
dr. Manhattan dead but if you guys are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys have a sub button to become
part of the rod core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all later purse
[Music]